[Music]
Here We Go Again December's ps+
essential lineup is here ready for your
Christmas time off the following games
can be downloaded from Tuesday December
the 5th and are yours to keep as long as
you are subscribed this month we have
Lego cleaning dirt and wandering in the
desert let's break them down game number
one is a racer like no other take a look
at Lego 2K drive a driving experience
that starts off as a cart racer and
morphs into the most UN limited vehicle
Creator ever seen in a video game the
massive open world of brick landia is
yours to explore finding races and other
events to unlock and complete the single
player story mode consists of a series
of Cup tournaments against quirky Rivals
across many disciplines track off-road
and even the open Waters as you master
drifting boosting and the usual powerups
found in cart races a load out of three
vehicles can be created and auto
switched between when their preferred
terrain approaches each switch coupled
with the addicting sound of Lego bricks
building side quests takes racing and
adds some weird and wonderful ways to
play from cooking a giant egg to playing
oversized golf in off-road vehicles Lego
Drive is both a single and multiplayer
racer which is only 6 months old right
now a solid cart racing experience with
the same rubber banding that makes Mario
Kart so engaging and frustrating on both
PS4 and PS5 Lego 2K Drive is rated 74%
on Metacritic will you give it a go next
again game many people want to try but
no one wants to spend their money on
this is power wash simulator on both PS4
and PS5 a simple idea a game in which
you clean away dirt it shouldn't work as
a video game but my gosh it does set in
first person armed with your trusty jet
of water we take to the streets of
mingham and grow our business by
impressing clients clients who really
shouldn't live in homes and businesses
this filthy let's see how long it takes
you to draw a the better job we do the
more money we earn which then feeds back
into our equipment our hose and fluids
can be upgraded if you get the cleaning
bug there are many DLCs set around more
famous locations in video games when the
PlayStation version first released it
was included with Lara croft's Tomb
Raider pack for free it's uncertain if
that is included in this ps+ version and
I'll add a comment below once I get that
confirmed power wash simulator there's
something addicting here and I don't
know what it is but I'm going to jump
back in again Metacritic 75 out of 100
and finally one more game Sable a desert
World exploration game without any
combat or game overs we play as sable a
young woman who must complete the right
of passage to be allowed back into her
tribe she must locate masks the game
wants the player to freely explore with
limited direction making the adventure
their own learning about the world
organically and stumbling across
locations and puzzles which then lead to
treasures and new abilities the art
style and camera angle can be annoying
at times as the minimal lines and colors
and a waywood camera can make simple
platforming more of a challenge than it
should be but overall this is a very
solid Zen Adventure game rated 8 out of
10 so that's our month what are you
playing in December I really recommend
that you try power wash simulator and I
do think Lego 2K is worth your time too
please let me know your thoughts in the
comments I'm Madam you're awesome I'll
see you next
[Music]
[Applause]
time
to